Rob here with a gamespot news update
rock band 4 developer Harmonix has
released the pricing details of the xbox
one and playstation 4 disc versions and
they're different the playstation 4
standalone discs will cost the standard
sixty dollars but the xbox one edition
carries an eighty dollar price tag the
price difference comes down to the Xbox
one edition requiring a legacy game
controller adapter this adapter allows
players to use their existing xbox 360
guitars and drum sets it supports up to
four controllers at the same time and
also works with a variety of third-party
instruments for ps4 no adapter is
required legacy rock band and
third-party guitars and drum sets will
work just fine out of the box without
any additional hardware pre-orders for
the standalone rock band 4 discs will
open today at retailers such as best buy
gamestop and amazon the rock band 4
release date is set for october sixth
across xbox one and playstation 4 for
the first time in franchise history the
game will also feature Van Halen
fantastic for all your gamespot news you
go to gamespot com